Are you
Hey
darling.
Hallelujah.
Well, this lecture is titled Earth's
Final Warning because that's basically
what it is. It is chapter 14 in the book
of Revelation which tells us what the
final message to a world gone berserk is
going to be.
Revelation chapter 14.
And I looked and lo a lamb stood on the
mount Zion and with him
144,000
having his father's name written in
their foreheads. Now, we've discussed
the 144,000 already, so I'm not going to
go into detail as far as they are
concerned, but they have the character
of God impressed in their minds,
the father's name written in their
foreheads. And I heard a voice from
heaven as the voice of many waters, and
as the voice of a great thunder, and I
heard the voice of harpers harping with
their hops. and they sung as it were a
new song before the throne. A new song
is a song of redemption. It is a song of
delivery. It's something that you cannot
understand unless you've had a
conversion experience or a delivery
experience. So this will be a song sung
with gusto which will be
essential or part of the redeem
and before the four beasts and the
elders and we've discussed them already
as well the covering cherubs and the 24
elders
and no man could learn that song but the
144,000
which were redeemed from the earth.
Obviously you cannot live someone else's
experience.
You cannot give someone else something
which you have not experienced yourself.
And so it is with the 10 virgins at the
end. There were 10 virgins at the end.
Each one of them was asleep.
All of them had oil. All of them had a
measure of the Holy Spirit. And then
when the bridegroom came, they all woke
up, but only half of them had enough oil
to make it to the wedding feast. And the
others didn't have enough oil. And so
they asked those who had to give some of
the oil. And they said, "But we cannot
give you any of our oil." And uh some
people say that's selfishness.
Why didn't they give them some of the
oil? I mean, what's the big deal? Well,
you cannot share an experience. You
cannot say, "Well, here's a part of my
experience. Let me pour that pour that
into your into your lamp." You'll have
to have had it yourself. You'll have to
have that experience with Jesus Christ
yourself. So, everyone needs oil.
Everyone needs this experience. And only
if you've had the experience can you
sing the song. It's the only way to sing
this song. You need the experience.
there. These are they which were not
defiled with women.
This always makes me sad this statement
because I had a colleague once who left
his wife because of that statement in
the Bible. Can you believe it how people
think? Literally left his wife because
of that statement in the Bible. And uh I
said to him, you know, I think you have
a wrong understanding about what a woman
is in the Bible. This has nothing to do
with physical contact between a man and
a woman. This is something that deals
with false worship. These are they who
have not defiled themselves with
apostate systems of worship. No, he was
convinced it was not defiling himself
literally with women. So I asked him one
more question. I said, "You've been
married all these years. Isn't it a
little bit late
if that is what you believe?
But uh as far as I know, he still is
away from his wife. But anyway, that's
not what it means. Obvious it means
these are they which have not defiled
themselves with apostate churches, for
they are virgins, they are with Christ.
These are they which follow the Lamb,
whether
he goeth.
These were redeemed from amongst men,
being the first fruits unto God, and to
the Lamb. And in their mouth was found
no guile, for they are without fault
before the throne of God. Why? Because
they have perfect righteousness.
Actually, they have, but it's not
theirs. that's imputed
and imparted righteousness.
So you know none of us are virgins,
none of us are virgins, but in Christ we
are because in him forgiveness is so
total that you have no sin and you are
as though you have never sinned and
therefore virgins in his eyes. What a
wonderful blessing that is. And no gile
was found in their mouths. When I think
about myself, wow, can I qualify? I had
a mind like a sewer all my life.
In their mouth was found no guile. Can
God just clean it up like that? Yes, he
can. Yes, he can. For they are without
fault before the throne. Why? Because he
is a spotless lamb and stands in
mystead. Isaiah chapter 48. Hear ye
this, O house of Jacob, which are called
by the name of Israel. Israel, those who
have wrestled with God, and have
overcome, who said, "I will not let you
go, lest you bless me." Don't give up.
Just hang in there. And then by faith
accept that it is so. and are come forth
out of the waters of Judah, which swear
by the name of the Lord, and make
mention of the God of Israel, but not in
truth, nor in righteousness. For they
call themselves of a holy city, and stay
themselves upon the God of Israel. The
Lord of hosts is his name. I have
declared the former things from the
beginning, and they went forth out of my
mouth, and I showed them, and they did
them suddenly, and I did them suddenly,
and they came to pass. So, there are
some people who declare that they are
the Lords. They are the lords. They are
the lords. But in actual fact, they're
relying on a system rather than relying
on God. There's no value in relying on a
system. None whatsoever. A system cannot
save you. A church cannot save you. That
doesn't mean that a that a church cannot
be a brotherhood and a sisterhood of
God's people. But the church cannot save
you. Only Jesus can save you.
So this is the one that you have to
trust. The one who declared the former
things from the beginning. They went
forth out of my mouth and I showed them
and I did them suddenly and they came to
pass. So you can test God by looking at
the prophecies because I knew that thou
art obstinate and thy neck is an iron
senue and thy brow brass. I have even
from the beginning declared it to thee
before it came to pass I showed it to
thee. Lest thou should say, mine idol
has done them, and my graven image and
my molten image has commanded them.
Isn't that fantastic? So, what is
prophecy there for?
To remind us that God is in control, to
remind us that he has the destiny of
humanity in his hands. And he tells us
ahead of time so that we see these
things we may believe. In the same way,
all the prophecy that we've dealt with,
will it save us?
No. But what it can do, it can teach us
that God, after all, is worthy of our
worship.
And that's the only thing that prophecy
can do. It cannot save you. Th heard,
Israel, see all this. Or, thou has
heard, see all this, and will not ye
declare it? I have showed thee new
things from this time, even hidden
things, and thou did not know them. Thou
art created now, and not from the
beginning, even before the day, when
thou heardest them not, lest thou should
say, "Behold, I knew them." Typical
humanity. We think we can declare
everything and explain everything
rationally.
This is not a rational world. In my own
life, I came to a point where I said,
"Well, this is not rational. I cannot
cope with this. there must be something
else. And then to find out that God had
foretold all the events of history ahead
of time so that I might believe that he
exists. Wow, that's really something.
You heardest it not. You knew it not.
Yet from that time, that time ear was
not open. For I knew that thou would
deal very treacherously and was called a
transgressor from the womb. That's all
we are. That's all we are. For my name's
sake I will defer mine anger, and for my
praise I will refrain for thee, that I
cut thee not off. Behold, I have refined
thee, but not with silver. I have chosen
thee in the furnace of affliction. H you
know how often have you heard people
that say Christianity is a crutch?
>> Have you heard that? I say, wow,
Christianity is a crutch. You come and
be a Christian. And here's my crutch.
Have fun.
Have fun with that crutch. I'll tell
you, Christianity is no crutch. It's a
furnace of affliction.
And it is painful sometimes. Why?
Because we have to change. It's about
character building. We have to develop
new characters in Jesus Christ. Do you
know today the psychologists if the
young people come together they go for
counseling and the psychologists say you
are not compatible.
You are you have to you are too
different. You have to be the same. You
have to have the same interest the same
this the same that and the same the
other. And so we are ruled by all these
things. What does God do?
He always puts opposites together. Have
you noticed that? He always creates the
worstc case scenario.
He does, you know, even in if he chooses
evangelists or whatever, he'll put a
Martin Luther who fire and brimstone
together with a mealon who's meek and
mild and gentle. I have a dear friend,
his name is France Duply.
Small little man like that. Man, do I
love that little man. He's absolutely
the opposite of me.
He always says, "Walter, you knock him
over. I'll pick him up.
He's sweet."
And he can do that. And he can put bomb
on. He says, "You get into the showroom.
I'll put on my overall and I'll change
the oil and put on the bandage
afterwards." You know, that's how he
works. So God puts together opposites.
Now this fire of affliction,
who can change your character other than
someone that you care about? Have you
noticed that? If I go to work and
there's a colleague there and he gives
me a hard time, I say bye and I go home,
he doesn't bother me. But what if my
wife gives me a hard time? I can't say
bye.
So something has to give, right?
And so men normally have these bombastic
characters. Although times are changing,
things are shifting round these days.
But nevertheless,
uh who can change you? God uses people
to change you and he uses those close to
you to change you. And the fire of
affliction is to show you your
character. Nobody can show you your
character more than someone who's close
to you. Nobody can do it. And if I'm
mean to someone and they don't care
about me, I'm not related to them,
they'll just ignore me and go away
forever. If I'm mean to my wife, what
then?
Well, she can fight back. She can do
that. But she can also be quiet and just
have a tear.
And that tear can be a lot worse than
fighting back. Have you noticed that?
Yes. So that really bugs you and worms
you and grinds you and gets into your
character and into your space and
eventually well you get to the point you
better start changing because you you
cannot be like this anymore. You have to
soften up. You have to be milder. You
have to be this. So God uses people you
love to help you change however painful
it is. And he says you work at it. So he
takes two people and he puts them in the
fire of affliction. And it's the same in
the church. If you ever thought the
church was going to be a hunky dory
place. Oh no. This these are brothers
and sisters of a different kinds.
Oh yeah. You have all kinds of fish in
this net. I'll tell you these these
fish. Serious fish. Some of them have
got heavy spines on them.
Some of these animals in the ark are
unbelievably sharp. Some, like the
rhinoceros, can give you a bump that you
are black and blue for six weeks. And
it's one of those situations where you
cannot walk away from it. I knew one
man,
shame, he's dead now, an old man, and he
was the most miserable son of a gun I've
ever seen in my life. He was the worst
thing that ever happened to me. Really,
he was. He was the worst thing that ever
happened to me. He screamed at me. He He
did everything in his power to destroy
everything I stood for. And he drove me
nuts. Sometimes, you know, I thought I
was going to modify him, but he was so
much older than me, so I had to be
respectful.
And for all these years, God put this
man into my life. And then he totally
left everything. He totally lost
everything. He even went together with a
prostitute, left his wife. Everything
went wrong.
And then just about four weeks ago,
he was dying in the hospital
and I got called to his place. So I went
to him and I sat there next to his
hospital bed and I looked at him and
there he was dying. They had already
amputated pieces. He was diabetic and he
was on his last last last legs. And I
sat there and I looked at him and I
thought to myself, "Wow, this hard nut
here." And he was still hard nut right
there on that bed on his deathbed.
And I thought, "What can I tell this
man?" And I said to him, "You know what?
You're the worst piece of meat that I
ever met. You've been so mean to me. and
I have given you one or two back. The
two of us, we were both two rocks in a
river and we were bashing each other and
I said, "You have been the very worst
thing I've ever met you. And you mean to
tell me you're going to die and it's all
for nothing?
All for nothing? All this pain we went
through for nothing?
I want this pain to be worth it and you
are going to be in heaven. Do you
understand me?
That's how I spoke. I've never spoken to
anyone like that on their deathbed
before. Never.
And he got quite contemplative.
And then he said to me,
"Yes, but it's too late." So I said,
"Why is it too late?" He says, "I've
messed up my entire life and I cannot
make it right."
So I said, "Join the club.
We have all messed up our entire life
and we cannot make it right. So why
don't you take your massive failure
and give it to Jesus Christ?
>> Why don't you give him your failure and
then he will make it right?" He says,
"Well, how do I go back and fix it? I've
left my wife. I'm living with this. I'm
doing this. I'm doing the other." Say,
"What are you going to do? You do you
think you're going to get up? You know
that you're on your last legs. You're
not going to fix that. Give that failure
to the Lord, too. So, I said, "Come back
tomorrow." So, I went back the next day
and we talked and it was so nice. The
tears started rolling down his eyes and
he gave his life to the Lord and
everything changed. He knew the truth.
He said to me, "You know, I hate it when
one group thinks they have the truth. I
hate it when they think they have the
truth. What right have they got to have
the truth?
It's true. You know, many people say,
"Well, you seventh day Adventists, you
think you have the truth. What a
miserable bunch." And everybody else,
what are they going to lie?
I said, you know, really, if you think
about it, it's not a complicated
doctrine. It's not a complicated
doctrine at all. It's love Jesus for
what he has done for you. give him the
honor and the glory and be obedient.
Isn't it logical to keep the
commandments of God? Yes, it's logical.
Then what's your problem? That's the
whole thing. Obedience and faith in his
merit. That's it. That's the gospel in a
nutshell. What's wrong with that?
Are you satisfied with a changed gospel,
a changed commandments, 10% discount in
our denomination or whatever? You only
have to keep nine, not one. we're a 10%
discount whatever and he started
thinking and he made his decision and he
died quite peacefully and you know what
I had the privilege of actually doing
the sermon at his burial and everybody
was there
his family was there his wife was there
his girlfriend was there they were all
together and they were all hugging each
other isn't that impossible that's fire
of affliction
So the Lord puts us in situations
where we come into contact with those
that we love and we can run away from
from it or we can allow it to change us.
And that's our choice. And if we create
tears and if we create pain then what we
can say is the problem lies with me. And
once I come to realize that the problem
lies with me, then God can work with us.
For my own sake, even for my own sake,
will I do it? For how should my name be
polluted? And I will not give my glory
unto another. Hearken unto me, oh Jacob
and Israel, my called. I am he. I am the
first. I also am the last. Mine hand
also has laid the foundations of the
earth. And my right hand has spanned the
heavens. When I call unto them, they
stand up together. Acknowledge God all
ye assemble yourselves and hear which
amongst you has declared these things.
The Lord has loved him. He will do his
pleasure on Babylon and his arm shall be
on the Calaldanss. See here now he's
comparing those who set up their own
standards who have their own religion
who don't need God. That's what the
Calaldanss stood for. Bab l another
portal to God. I even I have spoken. I
have called him. I have brought him and
he shall make his way prosperous. Come
ye near unto me. Hear ye this. I have
not spoken in secret from the beginning
and from the time that it was there I
am. And now the Lord God and his spirit
has sent me. Thus says the Lord thy
redeemer, the Holy One of Israel. I am
the Lord thy God, which teacheth thee to
profit, which leadth thee by the way
that thou should go. And God knows best.
Why not follow him?
>> Oh that thou hast hearkened to my
commandments. You see the whole gospel
is here in this little piece. Then had
thy peace been as a river and thy
righteousness as the waves of the sea.
God's commandments are an expression of
his love. Thy seed also had been as the
sand and the offspring of thy boughs
like the gravel thereof. His name should
not have been cut off nor destroyed from
before me. Go ye forth of Babylon, flee
ye from the Calaldanss. With a voice of
singing, declare ye, tell us, utter it
even to the end of the earth. Say ye,
the Lord has redeemed his servant Jacob.
Can you see the gospel there?
Stay away from that which says, I can do
it. I can reach God myself by my works.
Whatever the system is, if we don't have
the Lord has done this, he has redeemed
me, we're not in the right religion.
This is the gospel.
If thou has hearkened to my
commandments, then thy peace
had been as a river, and thy
righteousness as the waves of the sea.
It's a not as complicated doctrine. It's
a very simple doctrine. We make it
complicated. So what is the final
warning to the world? It's embodied in
the three angels messages and we find
them in the book of Revelation just
subsequent to the verses that we've
already read. The first angel's message.
What is that all about? Well, let's read
it. And I saw another angel. That's a
messenger flying in the midst of heaven,
spreading his light across the whole
heavenly divide, having the everlasting
gospel to preach unto them that dwell on
the earth. and to every nation and
kindred and tongue and people, saying
with a loud voice, "Fear God and give
glory to him, for the hour of his
judgment is come, and worship him that
made heaven and earth and the sea and
the fountains of water." Again, over
there, Revelation 14:6 and 7, you have
the seal of God.
So the first angel's message says we're
living in judgment time.
Pay attention to the word worship God.
Worship God. Worship him who made the
heavens, the earth, the sea, and the
fountains of water. What do I have to do
to tell the world that I acknowledge him
as such? Simple. Just keep the Sabbath.
Why?
Because that's the heart of the Sabbath
commandment. In six days the Lord made
the heavens, the earth, the sea, and
what them is. Therefore, he commanded
you to keep holy the Sabbath day. In
Deuteronomy chapter 5, you were slaves
in Egypt, and the Lord took you out of
there with a mighty hand and an
outstretched arm. Therefore, the Lord
commanded you to keep holy the Sabbath
day. The Sabbath is a sign of creation.
The Sabbath is a sign of redemption. He
took us out of the land of sin and
brought us into the fountain of his
grace.
So as we were created by him, so we were
redeemed by him.
If you look at the Jewish system, there
were seven annual Jewish feasts in type
and antitype.
There was the Passover Nissan 14
and that represented the crucifixion
because there the lamb was slain and the
blood of the lamb was painted on the
doorposts.
And so we have to put the blood of the
lamb on the doorposts of our heart and
then the angel of the Lord that will
come in judgment will pass us by. So if
we accept our Passover that was
sacrificed for us, then we acknowledge
the crucifixion, the lamb that died in
ourstead.
The second Jewish feast was the feast of
unleven bread. Notice it was the very
next day, Nissan 15. The unleven bread,
the bread without yeast, represents
what? the body of Jesus Christ. Jesus
Christ in the grave.
So he was crucified for us and he died
for us. Rested in the grave on the
seventh day and the very next day was
Nissan 16 was the first of first the
fruit of feast of first fruits and that
represents the resurrection.
Jesus the first fruits. He's the one who
was raised from the dead and the graves
opened up and people came out of their
graves says the Bible and when he went
into heaven he took captives in his
train that is the resurrection.
So in their annual feasts, the Jews were
actually
preempting the greatest event in history
that would come and the crucifixion, the
death in the grave and the resurrection
was celebrated in their feasts. Then I
had the feast of weeks
which was on 6 and that commemorated the
same time period after the Passover that
it took before the law was issued. And
then came Pentecost
and it typified the giving of the law of
course was a type and the outpouring of
the Holy Spirit spreading the message
abroad was part of their annual feasts a
type of Pentecost.
And then there were three other feasts.
The feast of trumpets tish one it
heralded the judgment second advent
movement a trumpets sounding saying a
great event is going to take place
trumpets were sounded before the
judgment so it heralded the judgment or
the second advent movement which says
the time of his judgment has come then
there was the day of atonement is 10
that's the pre-advent judgment
Obviously
God is judging because when he comes
again his reward is with him. Isn't that
right? So if he comes with his reward
then obviously he's prejudged. So that
judgment is taking place in heaven at
the moment. So that was the day of
atonement and it represented this time
when the high priest was in the most
holy and when he came out of there then
the sins were in type transferred to the
goat and he was led off in the
wilderness. Note he didn't die. So he
didn't become a sin bearer and and a
substitute. He was taken away and the
sins that had been confessed were
removed from the sanctuary and eternally
wiped off as though they had never
existed. And the final feast they had
was tish 15, the feast of tabernacles
where they made boos for themselves and
celebrated in great happiness. That is
the type of homegoing, the second
advent. So in the annual Jewish feasts,
you had the whole gospel story embodied.
The day of atonement is the annual
cleansing of the earthly sanctuary. So
there the high priest went in with the
blood and he officiated in the most holy
and he made atonement for the entire
sanctuary coming out cleansing the
sanctuary of the record of sin. So the
day of atonement was a day of judgment.
The day of judgment had come. The high
priest took
blood and he went into the most holy and
he sprinkled it and he made atonement
for the sanctuary and the uncleanness of
the people. Now what is the standard of
judgment? James tells us James chapter 1
verse 25. But who so lookketh into the
perfect law of liberty
and continuth therein, he being not a
forgetful hearer, but a doer of the
work, this man shall be blessed in his
deed.
James 2:12, so speak ye and so do as
they that shall be judged by the law of
liberty. Wonderful name for it, the law
of liberty. The law sets you free. It's
not a law of bondage. If everybody had
to keep the law on this planet, wouldn't
we all be free?
Yes or no? Absolutely. There's logic in
it. Your peace would have been like a
river and your righteousness like the
sea had everybody kept the law. What is
sin? Whosoever committh sin transgresses
also the law. For sin is the
transgression of the law. 1 John 3:4.
That's what sin is. So if you want to
have a relationship of obedience, well,
you have to keep the law of God. Where
no law is, there is no transgression.
Romans 4:15. So there must have been a
law from the beginning. Yes or no?
Otherwise, there would have been no
transgression.
For the wages of sin
is death.
But what is the little verse that comes
thereafter?
>> Ah, but the gift of God
is eternal life. Isn't that so? Through
his righteousness. So this is the full
gospel. Wages of sin, death, gift of
God, eternal life in J in Christ Jesus.
Now wages is something that you get for
what you do. Isn't that right? So if you
choose to break the law of God, the
consequence is death. The solution to
that since we all did that is salvation
by faith through grace. Isn't that
right? We are all saved by grace. Does
that mean we must leave this sentence
out that we should not sin? Sin
separates from God. Your iniquities have
separated you from your God. Isaiah
59:2.
For the wages of sin is death, but the
gift of God is eternal life through
Jesus Christ our Lord. There's the whole
verse. This is an everlasting gospel.
Sin kills.
Life is in Christ. So accept life in
Christ and stop
sinning. Is that biblical?
What did Jesus say to the woman caught
in adultery?
>> Yes, exactly. He says, "Where are your
accusers?" And she answers, "I don't
know, le Lord, they have left." And he
says, "Neither do I condemn you." That's
grace.
Go and sin no more. Or what is that?
Obedience. That's the everlasting
gospel. But today the world has modified
the everlasting gospel. They always
leave one arm, one leg of it out. You
have to have the full story. For sin
shall not have dominion over you, for
you are not under the law, but under
grace. What then shall we sin because we
are not under the law but under grace?
God forbid. Romans 6:14 and 15. Is the
law done away with because we are under
grace? Should we now break the law
because we are under grace? No. Remember
that quote from the charismatic churches
that I read where it said that if you
keep the law of God, you haven't got the
Holy Spirit. Wow. What kind of gospel is
the world teaching today? Therefore, by
the deeds of the law, there shall no
flesh be justified in his sight. For by
the law is the knowledge of sin. Romans
3:19 and 20. So I'm not saved by my good
works. I'm saved because I have a
savior.
>> Absolutely. That's the only reason why
I'm saved. But the law tells me what's
right and wrong. And therefore, I know
what's right and wrong and I can
distinguish. Do we then make void the
law through faith? God forbid. Yeah, we
established the law. Romans 3:31.
So in other words, we should be doers of
the law, not to save ourselves,
but because we love the Lord.
>> Wherefore the law is holy, and the
commandment is holy and just and good.
Romans 7:12. There's no such thing as we
don't have to keep the law of God. Four
gospels, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
People say, you know, they repeat each
other. They don't.
They augment each other, yes, but they
don't repeat each other. In Matthew,
Christ is depicted as the king. In Mark,
Christ is depicted as the servant. In
Luke, Christ is depicted as fully man.
In John, he's depicted as fully divine.
All of it in one. If we want to
represent the everlasting gospel, we
have to put law and grace into
perspective. And we have to serve Jesus
as king. We have to emulate him as
servants. He was a man. He died for us
so that he can feel our humanity and
share in our weaknesses. And we must
acknowledge him as God. There's nothing
less. Cannot demote him. The five books
of Moses, Genesis, the book of origins,
the fall, and the promise of redemption.
Exodus, Christ our sanctuary. He's the
one who leads us. the pillar of cloud
and the pillar of fire.
Leviticus, Christ our sacrifice.
Numbers, Christ our guide. Deuteronomy,
Christ our reward. The whole Bible is
about Jesus Christ. That's the
everlasting gospel. Don't you think the
world has missed out somewhere along the
line? No. Some people say we only need
the New Testament. Say, "Well, why
bother carrying such a heavy book? Get a
nice pair of scissors and cut the rest
off. Throw it away if you don't need it
anymore. No, the Old Testament and the
New Testament, they all talk about
Jesus. Think not that I am come to
destroy the law of the prophets. I have
not come to destroy, but to fulfill. For
verily, verily, I say unto you, till
heaven and earth pass. One jot or one
tit will shall no wise pass from the law
till all be fulfilled. Matthew 5:17 and
18. The everlasting gospel must be
preached.
It is easier for heaven and earth to
disappear than for the least stroke of a
pen to drop out of the law. Luke 16:E1
17. Not one iota of the law is going to
disappear. Even the NIV has it right.
This is love for God to obey his
commands. Would be better if they had
commandments like the King James has it.
And his commands commandments are not
burdensome. 1 John 5:3,
his commandments are not burdensome. And
being made perfect, he became the author
of eternal salvation unto them that obey
him. Hebrews 5:9. So the world has
deemphasized obedience and overemphasize
salvation by grace. Salvation by grace
is the primary. There is no doubt about
it because without that we are all lost.
But without obedience,
we won't get there either.
So the law of God has been done away
with. Then why do you find it in the New
Testament? This is the New Testament.
Thou shalt worship the Lord thy God, and
him only shalt thou serve. Matthew 4:10,
Revelation 19:10.
Little children, keep yourselves from
idols. 1 John 5:21. Acts 17:29.
That the name of God and his doctrine be
not blasphemed. 1 Timothy 6:1. The
Sabbath was made for man and not man for
the Sabbath. Therefore, the Son of Man
is Lord also of the Sabbath. Mark
2:27:28, Hebrews 4:4. Honor thy father
and thy mother. Matthew 19:19, Ephesians
6:13. Thou shalt not kill. Romans 13:9,
James 2:11. Thou shalt not commit
adultery. Matthew 19:18. Thou shalt not
steal. Romans 13:9, Ephesians 4:20. Thou
shalt not bear false witness. Romans
13:9. Thou shalt not coveret. Romans
7:7. So you're in trouble if you're
saying the law has been done away with
in the New Testament because there it is
in the New Testament. You're in big
trouble. So we cannot eliminate the law
of God. The tabernacle was pitched in
the midst of the people. Jesus in the
midst of his people. That's what it
stands for. The everlasting gospel. It
has never ever changed. The lamb of God
that takes away the sins of the world.
It was brought to the high priest. It
died instead of the sinner. Every Jew in
the past was saved by the blood of the
lamb. There's no such thing as the Jews
were under law and we are under grace.
Then how come a Jew had to bring a lamb?
Because he was under grace. Because he
was under grace. That's why. Behold the
lamb of God which takes away the sins of
the world. John 1:29,
"My little children, these things write
unto you that you sin not. And if any
man sin, we have an advocate with the
father, Jesus Christ the righteous." 1
John 2:9.
I was speaking to a Muslim once and he
said to me, "You Christians have an easy
life." I said, "Why?" He says, "You
Christians, you just do whatever you
like. You sin and then you say, "Forgive
me and it's done and you sin some more."
We can't do that.
I said, "Yeah, that's what Christianity
has become. You're right. I actually
stand ashamed before you that that is a
fact. Is that real Christianity? Did
Christ die so that we can continue
sinning?"
I don't think so.
True Christianity is acknowledging the
sacrifice of Jesus Christ and asking him
to clean up our act.
>> To get off our high horse
and to acknowledge our weakness and our
sin and to cling to the advocate. It's
the only hope we have. Do you know how
fortunate we are that the great judge of
the universe also happens to be our
advocate?
Can you imagine anything nicer than
that? The judge who's going to judge you
is also your advocate. The judge says,
you know, I think you are guilty of
this. And then the same judge says, yes,
but I paid the price.
Wow.
But did you then say thank you? Thank
you. and love the Savior so much that
you
stop doing what you did before. If you
were given a reprieve in a prison cell
for some wicked deed that you had done,
would it be right to say, "Well, now I'm
free to go and do it again and again."
Some actually do that, you know. Or
would it be better to say, "I have, wow,
I've been given a prie. I will never do
that again." Which one would be the
better of the two options? Obviously,
the latter.
He was wounded for our transgression. He
was bruised for our iniquities. The
chastisement of our peace was upon him.
And with his stripes, we are healed. If
we confess our sins, he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness. 1
John 1:9.
I was once talking to a minister and he
said to me, "The law has been done away
with. You're a legalist."
I said, "Wow, do you mind if I take your
wife home with me tonight?"
That's might be a bit harsh. Of course,
my wife was with me, so I could say
that. But the fact of the matter is then
he said, "No, of course not." I said,
"Well, what if I killed one of you of
you? Would that be okay? Or how about if
I took your car? Or how about, you know,
and I went through the ten commandments?
That's still there. Which one is the
problem?
The Sabbath is the problem, not the
other nine. But because there is no
argument, they have to sometimes get rid
of it all to get rid of the one.
If we confess our sins, he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
That is the crux
of the first angel's message. We're
living in judgment time. There's an
everlasting gospel. It has never
changed. We have nullified it. We have
cauterized it. We have cut it into half.
We must go back to the original. And we
must acknowledge the one who made the
heavens, the earth, the sea, and the
springs of water. That's what we have to
do. That's the first angel. And then
followed a second angel.
The second angel's message
is a frightening message.
You see, if you reject the message of
the first angel,
then you are rejecting light. And if you
reject light, eventually you will sit
where?
In darkness. So what does the second
angel's message say?
And there followed another angel,
saying, "Babylon is fallen, is fallen,
that great city, because she made all
the nations drink of the wine of the
wroth of her fornication." Revelation
14:8. That's the second angel's message.
It's a powerful message.
And this is a message that must go to
the entire world. So what point is there
if I go to the world and I say to them,
"World, Babylon is fallen."
Would that make any difference?
Wouldn't I have to explain to someone
what Babylon is before I can tell them
that it's fallen? Yes or no?
>> Absolutely. If people don't know what
Babylon is, then what's the point of
giving this message? So who is Babylon?
You have to go to ancient Babylon to
find out what Babylon is. What was
Babylon? Babylon was a religious system
that was very very uh wow
attractive to the Israelites and they
went and chose that religion nine times
out of 10 over their own religion. They
kept on going back to Babylon. Why?
Because it's so much more comfortable to
have your own way to God rather than
listen to his requirements. The wine of
Babylon. What is the wine of Babylon?
The wine of Babylon is false doctrine.
Two selected messages. 682.
The wine of Babylon is the exalting of
the false and sparious Sabbath above the
Sabbath which the Lord Jehovah has
blessed and sanctified for the use of
man. Also the immortality of the soul.
These kindred heresies and the rejection
of the truth convert the church into
Babylon.
kings, merchants, rulers, religious
teachers are all in corrupt harmony.
Yes, today the church is following or
the the rulers of the world are
following the church. Revelation 16:13
and 14. And I saw three unclean spirits
like frogs come out of the mouth of the
dragon,
out of the mouth of the beast, and out
of the mouth of the false prophet. For
they are the spirits of devils working
miracles which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the battle of that great
day of God Almighty. Revelation 16:13
and 14. Scary.
All right. And in actual fact, we're
talking about the Babylon system
consists of three components
and they're run by unclean spirits like
frogs.
Frogs were one of the plagues in Egypt
because frogs were one of the were
deities in the Egyptian system.
So here they are and they're out of the
mouth of the dragon, the beast and the
false prophet. Those three components
and they're spirits of devils working
miracles.
Counteracting that he has the patience
of the saints. He are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. Revelation 14:12. two messages.
What are these messengers? And who is
this woman Babylon that has the whole
world worshiping at its feet? So, mystic
Babylon has these three components. The
dragon, the beast, and the false
prophet. And we've dealt with them in
quite some detail in these lectures.
Here's a bronze frog.
And uh this is in Japan where they have
the worship of their deity which is
father, mother, child just like the Isis
Osiris system and they still worship
these frogs on the outside. So don't
think this worship system is over. It's
the ancient old Babylonian system of
worship. Bronze frog combined the sun
with water symbolizing fertility. So
UNESCO tells us they should know what is
the dragon. Well, the dragon is
identified in the Bible as Satan, that
old serpent. So everything that deals
with spiritism,
where demonic forces directly
orchestrate mankind is part of the
dragon system. So that would include,
for example, witchcraft. Does witchcraft
lead astray? But witchcraft, what has
that got to do with the church? What if
the church starts saying we must hold
seances as the church of England did?
Doesn't witchcraft then become part of
the church?
Doesn't the Babylonian worship system
creep into the church? Who are these
priests of Rome?
The wandering bishops who deal with the
occults and run the scenes behind the
new age movement.
What about world philosophy? A rand the
virtue of selfishness.
Is there virtue in selfishness?
No. But in human thinking, there is
virtue in selfishness.
In fact, Robert Schuler teaches
self-esteem
is what you really need. Not God esteem,
self-esteem.
I thought he must increase, I must
decrease. Did you know something which
is a little secret? And that is that
truth and error are like this.
They are like this. Do you know if you
are willing to surrender your
self-esteem to Christ,
you actually increase in in esteem?
It's amazing, but it's a fact. Think
about it. Because you have the God of
the universe
acknowledging you as his child. You come
become a a son or a daughter of the most
high, a prince to sit on a throne
together with him.
>> Wow. If that isn't something, then what
is? But you have to learn humility from
him in order to qualify. Here we're
learning something else.
What about what we heard from this
lovely lady JC Knight? You are God.
Forget about Jesus Christ. He's just one
of the crowd. Spiritism in all its forms
where man sets him upself up as a god to
be worshiped. So we have all the god
kings, the dalai lamas, all these people
in the worship systems of the world. And
these worship systems are all coming
together in the United Nations to form
one big united religions. And we have to
acknowledge the same deity behind them
all. I have a problem with that. How can
I acknowledge a deity that exalts self
if I worship a deity that stands for
humility?
The two are incompatible.
But all of these are coming together
into one super system. Bhagwan Shri
worshiped as a human being. Does it
really give you self-esteem? It robs you
of your dignity or matraa as he appeared
in Nairobi and people worshiping him as
Jesus Christ. We are told in the
churches today that Harry Potter is just
great and kids dress up as Harry Potter
to come and practice his values in the
church. This is witchcraft.
So has the church not incorporated
witchcraft in its systems? Yes or no? At
least tolerated it. There are many many
in the church who are horrified as they
see what is happening. And I presume God
is permitting it to get worse and worse
and worse and worse so they can wake up
and see what has become of the church.
The church has become Babylon
by allowing dragon worship into its very
midst. What about modern modern
spiritualism where the fox sisters?
There they are. Started with a rapping
tap tap tap tap tap. Eventually, it went
into full-blown seances and demonic
worship.
Well, we saw that the founding fathers
of the modern Christian movements, the
psychic research organizations where the
great bishops, Westcot, Hort all of
these that actually rewrote the Bible
for us if you like that they had their
ghost societies and communicated with
spirits. Isn't that spiritualism in the
church? Spiritualism says that the dead
know more than the living and the
serpent said unto the woman, "Ye shall
not surely die." Genesis 3:4.
In this case, as in many other Bible
passages, the devil told the truth and
the Lord is in error. EW Sprag, a
spiritualist
straight out. They don't mince words.
The fundamental principle of spiritism
is that the human beings survive bodily
death and that occasionally under
conditions not yet fully understood we
can communicate with those who have gone
before. Jay Arthur Hill spiritism
history phenomenon and doctrine page 25.
This is spiritism in the world. The
Bible says when you die you're dead.
Your only hope is the resurrection.
That's your only hope.
Spiritism claims the dead communicate.
There is no death in the graveyard. I
have frequent talks with the dead. I
cannot doubt that the people live after
death, for I frequently talk with them.
Sir Oliver Lodge said, "Well, modern
kings do it all over the place. Prince
Charles has regular sessions with Mount
Batton, who's been dead for a very long
time, and he's the head, official head
of the Church of England.
Is there spiritism in the church? Yes or
no? Absolutely there's spiritism in the
church. Progressive thinker May 181
1929. What spiritualism is and does. It
removes all fear of death which is
really the portal to the spirit world.
It teaches that death is not a cessation
of life but a mere change of condition.
Spiritualism is God's message to mortals
declaring that there is no death. What
does that do with God? Makes him a what?
>> Makes him a liar. That's right. That all
who have passed on still live. That
there is hope in the life beyond for the
most sinful. That every soul will
progress through the ages to heights
sublime and glorious where God is love
and love is God. The world out there is
living a lie.
I have spiritualistic
seance information tapes if you like of
a session with
Ceil John Rhodess. Of course, he's dead,
but he speaks to the spiritist and he
explains what who the hierarchy is in
the he on the other side and the most
wicked people on this earth according to
this spiritualistic seance
are higher than Jesus Christ on the
other side. Adolf Hitler, for example,
is higher on the other side than Jesus
Christ because he had more experience
here on earth than he gained. Can you
believe that? Well, these are terrible,
terrible doctrines. Doctrines of devils
being propagated in churches because
virtually all churches today
propagate this doctrine of continued
life. Who did Alice A Bailey speak to
when she spoke to Dwalk? If the dead are
waiting for the resurrection, then who
did she speak to? Who is Dwalk?
He's a demon. That's what he is. Here's
the official website of the Church of
Satan.
This man over here, Anton Leave. Do they
have good doctrines? Yes. But the church
of Satan is a recognized church in the
world standing side by side with the
other churches in a community of all the
churches. What has light and darkness
got in common? Has the world gone mad?
Is the high priest of Satanism? is
supposedly responsible for I don't know
how many sacrifices of humans
and uh satanic news on the march. What
does the satanic bible say? 1969 Anton
Levy the founder Satan represents
indulgence instead of abstinence. Satan
represents vital existence instead of
spiritual pipe dream. Satan represents
undefiled wisdom instead of hypocritical
selfdeceit. Satan represents kindness to
those who deserve it instead of love
wasted on ingrates.
Do
>> you know what the kingdom of heaven is
made of such as these? Go ye into the
highways and byways and go and fetch the
lame and the crippled and the this and
the that. How often we despise them. No,
no, no. Love them. Take them into the
arms of the church because they will
make up the kingdom of heaven. Let Satan
laugh at our weaknesses and at our
crippled minds and at our crippled
bodies. He ain't seen nothing yet. Wait
till they are transformed and receive
that which God has in store for us. He
will still be judged by them.
So, Satan represents vengeance instead
of turning the other cheek. Satan
represents responsibility to the
responsible instead of concern for
psychic vampires.
Satan represents man as just another
animal, sometimes better, more often
worse than those that walk on all fours,
who because of his divine spiritual and
intellectual development, has become the
most vicious animal. So, we're gods.
Same teaching. Satan represents all of
the so-called sins as they all lead to
physical, mental, and emotional
gratification.
And Satan has been the best friend the
church has ever had as he has kept it in
business all these years. That's Anton
Lee's Bible.
Now if you look at it, how much of this
is actually slipped into church
doctrines today?
Surprising frightful amount. The
allseeing eye of Lucifer. Well, there
are some interesting things here. The
wedge of the eye. This little thing here
in the middle. The Eye of Lucifer. Did
you know that? That was the first little
computer game in the world. Pac-Man.
Remember that? Gobbled up everything.
Yeah. Interesting. Oh.
So spiritism, the dragon component is
everything that has to do with demonic
activity dressed up sometimes as
churchy, sometimes as pure demonic
Satanism. And all are welcome in the
folds of Babylon. What about the beast?
Well, that's Catholicism.
Unfortunately,
that's what the Bible teaches. All the
attributes of the papacy applied to the
beast power. He's the one who has the
sign of Horus
and the world religion will be subject
to him. He's all things to all men.
There he receives the tilak in Hinduism.
There he kisses the Quran. We've dealt
with these things. A dead Christ
cannot communicate.
A body of Christ as God literally making
God from a morsel of bread.
Well, can he save you? No. Believe me, I
tried to talk to him. He doesn't answer.
He doesn't answer.
And substituting Mary, this is the code
of arms of the Vatican, the dragon on
the papal crest in the Vatican museum.
Vatis, diver, serpent. Vatican, divining
serpent. That's what it means. So, we
follow the beast power. We're in
trouble. Revelation 13:4. and they
worshiped the dragon
which gave power unto the beast and they
worshiped the beast saying who's like
unto the beast who is able to make war
with them so if we acknowledge Rome as
the spiritual head of the churches
well then we are acknowledging the
leadership of Babylon rather than the
leadership of Jesus Christ
at what then do the Jesuits aim
according to them they only seek the
greater glory of God. But if you examine
the facts, you will find that they aim
at universal dominion alone. They have
rendered themselves indispensable to the
pope who without them could not exist
because Catholicism is identified with
them. They have rendered themselves
indispensable to governance, hold
revolutions in their hand, and in this
way either under one name or another, it
is they who rule the world.
It's just the fact all these revolutions
we spoke about, all this death and all
this mayhem under their control so that
by creating chaos they can create the
world order that they want and we have
to be subject to them.
So that is the other component of
Babylon. Who's the false prophet? That's
very sad.
And I saw another beast coming up out of
the earth. It had two horns like a lamb.
This was another Christian system. Spoke
like a dragon. And we discussed this in
Revelation 13. This was the
Protestant United States coming up and
taking power and making an image unto
the beast, becoming like it. And
Protestantism, which is supposed to
stand for freedom and righteousness, is
actually today masonry in disguise.
Statue of liberty, it's masonic. A holy
alliance, which is a unholy alliance.
The wall of separation between church
and state is a metaphor based on bad
history.
And so Rome would bound the Protestant
churches adopted
beast c characteristics
and the church of England here changed
its face and became like the beast. We
discussed all that and we had a look at
all their teachings and what they are
teaching and how it's totally contrary
to the Bible. What Schula said, what the
Bible said, all these things how Schula
said, "And we can pray our father in
heaven, honorable is our name." To be
born again means that we must be changed
from a negative to a positive selfimage.
A religion based on self, a religion
based on worldly values, a religion
honoring mankind to the level of deity,
this is sin. This is sin and needs to be
called by its right name whether Billy
Graham endorses it or not.
The Bible and the Bible alone.
Whether he sits with the pope or not he
has endorsed it.
What about the charismatic movement? It
says when he says I am, I just smile and
say yes I am too.
Is this still Christianity?
I don't think so. Promise keepers,
Kenneth Hagen magazine, obelisks, and we
have a form of godliness
denying the power thereof.
It's very sad. Or penny hinn which says
I am, I am, I am, I am. Don't say I
have, say I am. You are everything he
was and everything he is and ever shall
be. Is that Christianity?
I don't think so.
So what is this? This is false prophecy.
This is false preaching. This is a lie
and it has to be exposed.
And so the dragon component in the
churches
and the beast component in the churches
and the false prophet component in the
churches has to be exposed for what it
is. And the message goes to the world.
Babylon is not what it seems. It's
fallen. It's fallen.
And then follows another angel.
Now, do you think the churches will
accept this rebuke? Yes or no?
No, they won't accept it. Will
individuals accept it?
Thank God for that. Or else all
preaching would be in vain. The third
angel's message, what does that say?
Revelation 14:9. And the third angel
followed them, saying with a loud voice,
"If any man worship the beast and his
image, and receive the mark, his mark in
his forehead or in his hand, the same
shall drink of the wine of the wroth of
God, which is poured out without mixture
into the cup of his indignation, and he
shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lamb."
Wow. Never has a message like that gone
out from God. This is powerful stuff.
And we've dealt with this actually
already because we've dealt with the
mark in the forehead and in the hand
when we dealt with Revelation 13. So I
point you to that. So what was it? What
was it all about? The same shall drink
of the wine of the wrath of God which is
poured out without mixture
without mercy this time total
destruction
into the cup of his indignation. And you
shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angel than in the presence of the lamb.
What does that mean? Two lectures coming
up on that storm. And the smoke of their
torment ascendeth up forever and ever.
What does that mean? And they have no
rest day or night who worship the beast
and his image and whosoever receiveth
the mark of his name. What does that
mean? What is this forever and ever and
ever and ever? Well, it'll take two
lectures to clarify it. the last two and
then we'll have eternal peace after
that. Revelation 14:9-10.
For in six days the Lord made the
heavens, the earth, the sea, and all
that in the me and rested on the seventh
day. Wherefore the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and hallowed it. Exodus 28.
Remember that it is a sign between me
and the Lord that he rested on the
seventh day and he was refreshed. And
the sign meant a mark. So God has a
mark. It is the Sabbath. We must
understand God's mark, his sign, his
seal. We went through this in Revelation
13. And the Lord delivered to me two
tablets of stone written with a finger
of God. They were not to be messed with.
Deuteronomy 9:10.
So God's seal, God's mark is in the
heart of his law. It's the Sabbath. And
it gives authority as we have said to
the whole law. Now
are we saved by keeping the law? No.
Let's get this quite clear. But without
keeping the law, will we be saved? No.
See, always asked the counter question
as well. Now the point is this. If we
are not saved by keeping the law, then
how are we saved?
By grace. Grace saves us 100%. Grace
saves us. We are saved by grace. So if I
now keep the law, what am I
acknowledging by keeping the law?
I'm acknowledging a higher authority
than myself. Is that correct? If I keep
the law, I am acknowledging a higher
power than myself. And if I keep it
exactly like he said, I'm acknowledging
his authority. Is that correct?
So whose righteousness am I
acknowledging?
Jesus's. So don't think that by saying
keep the law, you are legalistic.
No. In actual fact, by keeping the law,
if you do it right, you are propagating
righteousness by faith
because you are acknowledging his
superiority in your life. You are
acknowledging
your dependence upon him and you come in
line with his wishes because you are
acknowledging
his fullness of understanding. Does that
make sense? So by not accepting man's
laws but accepting God's laws, I
acknowledge my dependence upon him and I
accept his righteousness
by faith.
So the mark of the beast message
involves righteousness by faith and
obedience as a consequence. As simple as
that. But the Lord creator, heaven and
earth, that's his stamp, his name, his
title, his territory. I gave them my
Sabbaths as a sign between me and them
that they might know that I am the Lord
that sanctifies them. So where does your
righteousness come from?
From him, not from me. This is
righteousness by faith. So the third
angel's message is righteousness by
faith in verity. Absolutely.
It could be construed as legalism
if you wanted to. But in actual fact,
what you are doing by keeping the law,
if you understand it correctly, is
acknowledging a higher power. And it
will be if you will listen carefully to
my commandments which I command you
today to take heed to yourselves that
your heart may not be deceived and you
turn aside and serve other gods and
worship them. Therefore, you shall lay
up these my words in your hearts and in
your souls, and bind them for a sign
upon your hand, so that they may be
frontlets between your eyes. John
Deuteronomy 11:13:20. So, we act
accordingly. We think accordingly.
And the mark of the beast, Sunday, is
our mark of authority. But they say it
themselves. The church is above the
Bible. And this transference of the
Sabbath observant is proof of that fact.
Catholic record September 123. She took
the pagan Sunday. She made it the
Christian Sunday. The pagan Sunday
dedicated to Bala became the Christian
Sunday sacred of to Jesus. And she
acknowledges it. She says, "Of course,
the Catholic Church claims that the
change was her act." And the act is a
mark of her ecclesiastical power. So
it's not a question so much of a day as
it is of authority. If I obey this
system, I am exalting human laws. And
basically, I'm saying I'm getting my
sanctification from whom?
From the church. And that's what she
wants. No church can give me
sanctification.
Not even the one that I'm in. No church
can give me sanctification. Only Jesus
Christ can give me sanctification.
That's it. No one else.
The Bible says, "Remember that thou keep
holy the Sabbath day." The Catholic
Church says, "No. By my divine power, I
abolish the Sabbath day and command you
to keep holy the first day of the week."
And lo, the entire civilized world bows
down in reverent obedience to the
command of the Holy Catholic Church,
Father Enright, American Sentinel.
They're pretty arrogant about it. Pretty
arrogant about it. So, who do I
acknowledge? The earthly powers or the
heavenly powers? That's the question.
Choose thee. Whom you want to
acknowledge, God or man? The power of
sanctification through God or the power
of sanctification through man which
leads to death. Because how can man save
you? Pope Pas 1566 commanded the council
of Trent. It pleased the church of God
that the religious celebration of the
Sabbath day should be transferred to the
Lord's day. Catechismos Romanos.
And unfortunately, all the world wonders
after the beast. So the third angel's
message is do not acknowledge man's law
superior to God's law. The test will be
the Sabbath.
Might they put a microchip into your
hand? Maybe. Maybe to control your
buying and selling. But a chip
is not your character of allegiance.
What your character of allegiance is is
obedience to God's commandments. They
must be on your forehead and on your
hand. The Catholic Church is happy if
it's on your hand or your forehead.
There's a subtle difference there. The
Bible says in Deuteronomy,
binded as frontlets between your eyes
and
your hand.
But the mark of the beast is in the
forehead or the hand. Why that subtle
difference?
Because the Catholic pre church is
satisfied if you keep it because you are
convinced it's right. But it's also
satisfied if you do it because you have
to
without acknowledging anything. Just
being obedient is good enough. Well,
it's not good enough. You be obedient to
God. He has the patience of the saints.
He that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus. Revelation 14. Well,
this message will become even more
powerful when in Revelation 18, after
these things, I saw another angel come
down from heaven having great power and
the earth was lightened with his glory.
And he cried mightily with a strong
voice, Babylon is fallen. Babylon is
fallen.
Now look what has happened. She has
become a habitation of devils and the
hold of every foul spirit, cage of every
unclean and hateful bird. Well, if you
reject God,
well, then you get demons.
For all the nations have drunk of the
wine of the wroth of her fornications,
and the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her, and the
merchants of the earth have waxed rich,
etc., etc., etc. And I heard another
voice saying, "Come out of her, my
people, that you be not partakers of her
sins, and that you receive not of her
plagues." So, God is going to call his
people out of Babylon. They have to come
out. They have to see that an earthly
system has been built up which does not
lead to righteousness and have no
fellowship with the unfruitful de works
of darkness but rather expose them.
Ephesians 5 11 that's the last message
of warning to the world. It's a tough
message. It's a very tough message and a
very unpopular message.
And then there will be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation even to that same time. When this
message finishes up,
this planet's not going to look the same
anymore.
And he that dwelleth in the secret place
of the most high shall abide under the
shadow of the almighty. Psalms 91
verse1. If you choose the Lord, you have
nothing to fear. He'll take care of you.
He's promised to do so. He didn't
promise you a rose garden. At least he's
not a liar. At least he didn't promise
you utopia and then doesn't deliver. He
says, "It's going to be tough, but I'll
take care of you."
And then a decree will go out. He that
is unjust, let him be unjust still. And
he which is filthy, let him be filthy
still. And he that is righteous, let him
be righteous still. And he that is holy,
let him be holy still. Probation closes.
The decision has been made.
And then
after these things, I saw another angel
come down from heaven with great power.
And the earth was lighted with his
glory. God's people will come out of
Babylon. And I heard a voice from
heaven, Revelation 14, 13, and 14,
saying unto me, write, "Blessed are the
dead which die in the Lord from
henceforth."
Strange sentence. Yay, says the Spirit,
that they may rest from their labors,
and their works do follow them. And I
looked, and behold, a white cloud, and
upon the cloud sat one like unto the Son
of Man, having on his head a golden
crown, and in his hand a sharp sickle.
What's a sickle for?
Harvest. Time of harvest. Well, if you
die, well, that's a blessing in a way
because the Lord will raise you up.
Nothing to fear. If you're alive, that's
a blessing because you'll see him
coming. Looking for that blessed hope
and the glorious appearing of the great
God and our savior Jesus Christ. Titus
2:13. It's the very next act. This is
the final message of warning to a world
followed by the coming of Christ.
For the great day of his wroth has come,
and who will be able to stand? Well,
we'll have to answer that question.
Revelation 6:17, and we'll look at it in
detail as we go into another lecture.
And another angel came out of the
temple, crying with a loud voice to him
that sat on the cloud, "Thrust in thy
sickle, and reap, for the time has come
for thee to reap, and for the harvest of
the earth is ripe." And he that sat on
the cloud thrust in the sickle on the
earth, and the earth was reaped.
So there's a redemptive reaping. And
another angel came out of the temple
which is in heaven also having a sharp
sickle. And another angel
came from the altar which had power over
fire and cried with a loud voice to him
that had the sharpsicle saying thrust in
the sharpsicle and gather the cluster of
the vine of the earth
for her grapes are fully ripe. So
there's a first harvest and now there's
a second harvest. And the angel thrusted
his sickle into the earth, and gathered
the vine of the earth,
and cast it into the great wine press of
the wroth of God. And the wine press was
trodden without the city, and blood came
out of the wine press, even unto the
horse's bridles
by the space of a,600
furong. What does all this mean? Well,
wine is doctrine. And here is a doctrine
of the earth as opposed to the heavenly
doctrine. And this doctrine will come up
and bury the horses. What did the horse
stand for? The gospel herald. So this
gospel herald that was spread from this
earth and was a lie because it was
earthly and left Jesus Christ out will
bury in its own be buried in its own
iniquity and it will disappear forever.
So the choice is between the one system
or the other. We either go with Christ
when he comes or we form part of the
other harvest. The choice is ours. And
that final message of warning,
as hard as it sounds, is a message of
love because it calls us to acknowledge
Jesus. Think of the simplicity of it. My
people, he's basically saying,
I love you.
It is time for judgment to come. Why
don't you leave the evil philosophies of
this earth? Why do you want to be
steeped in evolution and all these
philosophies? Why don't you acknowledge
me as your creator and your redeemer?
Why do you want to follow philosophies
that exalt the human
and denigrate the divine?
Why don't you want to look up for your
salvation than look down?
Don't you want to obey me and my
precepts so that it may be well with
you? Don't you want to acknowledge me
because I am the one who sanctifies you
and makes you whole and makes you sons
and daughters of the most high? That's
the message. Isn't it a nice message?
It's a sweet call from the Lord above
saying, "Come my children. Why would you
be lost?"
And you can listen or you can reject.
That's the final message to this world.
It's tough, but I believe it's true.
Amen.
I got
home.
Oh,
hey.
glory
for you.
Oh,
you go home.
Go.
Oh.